i challenged five top level anime
youtubers to convince me of their
favorite characters in exactly three
minutes we have grand line review my
name is liam packing 101 my favorite
character you say pda law i rest my case
joy girl this is your girl and anime
bald steam choosing your favorite
character isn't easy not only some of my
favorite anime people but they're also
all creators that know what they're
talking about way more than me most of
the time which i guess is not the
biggest compliment there is each of them
will now try to convince you me and each
other that their character is the best
any animal manga counts at the end each
of them gets to vote for exactly one
video except their own of course the
winner will get a secret custom prize
here from japan that i'll reveal at the
end i can't wait to see what everyone
has come up with
hello and welcome to the best character
you'll ever see in all of media probably
my name is liam and i am not that
character in fact i'm not the best at
anything really which is a bit sad but i
am here to introduce you to the best
character in all of media and that
character is whitebeard
dog whitebeard's dog this precious
papa's name is stefan and he makes his
one and only appearance in one piece
volume 58. he exists solely because a
fan asked series author echo oda if
whitebeard ever removes his moustache in
order to use it as a boomerang to which
oda said why yes yes he does but only
when he's taking his dog stephan for a
walk walks being a rather notoriously
difficult thing to do in one piece due
to all of the uh the water and stuff but
as a seafaring papo stefan was well and
truly a pirate many pirates in fact as
depending on the day stefan abandons his
crescent moustache to become characters
such as pup gasty ace kozuki odog and
even goldie doggo and just as
whitebeard's fame sword so did stefan's
in fact there was a point where the
walled document even issued him with a
bounty of 5400 tritos thus becoming the
most wanted dog in the world and if you
ever want to test whether or not your
favorite character is in fact better
than stefan somehow then you need only
ask yourself one simple question is your
character a dog with a crescent mustache
and if the answer is no well then it's
not looking good however if even that
has failed to convince you that i'm
afraid that you leave me with no choice
but to use the power of music
[Music]
but his cuteness is a weapon
he is
[Music]
in conclusion stefan is the literal
underdog and you simply must vote for
him or not i mean i'm not your mother
but your mother would be very very
disappointed in you if you did not vote
for stefan so
yeah
okay i think i think my brain is still
trying to find the appropriate reaction
to this definitely not what i expected
at all but it's absolutely glorious who
was that singing i mean liam is not only
an expert in anything anime and manga
but i have a real weak spot for dry
sarcasm delivered with a straight face
so straight a from me also since liam
loves doing subscribe games how about
this game if you are subscribed to the
grandland review you have to subscribe
here as well i think i did that wrong
anyways next let's hear from tekking
about his favorite character
my favorite character you say well
that's a really difficult question no
it's not it's frankie from one piece
let's talk about him now some of you
might be surprised by that some of you
might not be and the fact that frankie
always ranks like the lowest in straw
hat popularity polls always stuns me
okay but this is the reason he's my
favorite he just checks all the boxes
okay first off he's got an awesome
design does that mean everything to a
main character of course not but he has
an awesome design he is a cyborg that is
so cool right not just for merchandise
and figurines or whatever but he's a
cyborg that built himself he's got giant
arm cannons and everything he's always
coming up with new devices he can fire
lasers from his hands so just in terms
of aesthetic and the fact that i'm a
huge fan of power rangers and everything
growing up frankie you know checks the
box there next his personality all right
frankie is a really super guy and he
loves what he does all right it's that
enthusiasm that i can really relate with
because what i'm doing right here is
talking about one piece and you know i
have my channel and i love to do it
frankie's the same thing with building
stuff okay when he's interested in
something he doesn't just do it
half-assed he goes all the way man he
does super that's his catchphrase for a
reason right when he wants to build a
bridge he doesn't just build a little
wooden bridge with some rope no he
builds a beautiful bridge with ornate
carvings in five minutes that's frankie
when frankie wants to build a new weapon
for the straw hats he doesn't just build
a tank no he builds a tank and a
motorcycle that can combine into a
megazord that's the franky way of doing
things and that is my philosophy in life
very much so and to top it all off he's
a weird character he's a weird character
that embraces his weirdness and he is
who he is and he doesn't care about what
other people think about him or whatever
he just goes through life at the beat of
his own drum he's a cyborg that runs on
soda for god's sake all right that is
weird in and of itself but no it's like
hey man this is who i am and you know
frankie's like in his 30s okay so i
think that also speaks to a lot of
people maybe like the older you get
there's sort of this um urge by society
you know it's time to grow up it's time
to act mature it's time to you know stop
watching power rangers and megazords and
all that kind of stuff and frankie's
like no man i'm in my 30s i love that
kind of [ __ ] this is what i'm all about
all right and so that's really cool for
me personally i mean frankie's always
been like as soon as he appeared in one
piece i knew i was gonna love this guy
and every story arc every battle he's
been and he doesn't get the most
elaborate fights but you know his fights
are always like hey i'm just gonna drive
this giant motorcycle on top of one of
the main villains faces and just like
yeah super and then just drive off all
right so just to summarize really quick
appearance awesome techniques amazing
battles super personality weird but
great so there you go my pitch on why
frankie is the single greatest character
ever a classic frankie is one of the
most underrated characters in one piece
for sure and i couldn't have explained
it even half as well as this man did
right here ridiculous incredible
knowledge you have there man i pulled my
imaginary hat before you sir wait i i
actually have one
okay so two one piece characters in a
row let's see if this keeps up
killer zoldick is not only my favorite
but one of the best anime characters of
all time the thing about killer's
journey is that he's not the main
character but he kinda is because him
and gone are the main characters at
least their relationship is but what
makes him better one could say they
thrive off of each other each makes up
for the other's deficiencies sure but
for kilauea it's a bit different he had
to change much more killer was
introduced as a cheeky and cheerful kid
and while we find out about gan's other
side in the chimera ant arc kilaueas rid
its head much earlier he was the heir
parent to the head of a family of
assassins he had been brutally trained
to be violent and deadly but also
manipulated by his older brother illumi
one of the main takeaways of illumi's
manipulation was to never engage unless
victories are but assured god is the
antithesis of this way of thinking
so i'm painting a picture of this cheeky
brat who's also an emotionless killing
machine but that's just the beginning
kilowatt every single arc goes to a
metamorphosis which is far from mundane
even though character growth is a staple
in hunter hunter kilowatt goes from the
cool kid on the skateboard to a much
more outgoing analytical goofball that
realizes gone is his light he even said
as much some may say that the khmer
antarct ruined their relationship
because gone seemed to not care about
killua after everything they had been
through but that's exactly because
that's what the relationship had been
kilowatt trying his hardest to be there
for gone no matter what the situation
was while gone could just be himself
because all he wanted was to be friends
with gone killua goes from an overcast
dark sky to a bright full moon because
of gone but what has gone become there's
a dark side to gom that killwood knows
all too well yet he still wants to stay
by his side the spiky-heared lightning
user who escaped the clutches of his
mother and brother received
acknowledgement from his father to be
himself stayed by his friend's side
through blood and death while saving his
sister or something aluka or nanika and
the thing is what gets lost here is that
kilauea is able to now see how important
it is for him to be there for nanika
because of the light that gone burned
into his heart so while kilauea was out
here literally taking hearts
gone took
his
[Music]
but so far i've only talked about the
deep aspects of killer's character i
could go into some of just the cool
things that kilauea does his design is
badass he can make a yo-yo look cool
also godspeed have you guys ever seen
godspeed
[Music]
[Music]
i rest my case oh wow this had a
completely different vibe from the first
two if you know anything about me i'm
always a big fan of dramatic music and
kilua is one of my favorite characters
in general anyways fantastic
presentation though i did miss that
excellent bda humor just a little bit
i'm gonna be honest this might be really
hard to top though let's get some female
input on this i'm sure it's gonna be a
super feminine character hello my
nakamatachi for those of you who don't
know me this is your girl and for those
of you who do you may be surprised to
find that my entry to this video of the
best mango anime character is not a
one-piece character because let's face
it i shouldn't have to convince you that
luffy and the straw hats is the best
character that's a given so today to
give myself a little challenge i'd like
to bring awareness to a certain
red-headed character sakura
sakuragi move over girl i'm trying to
win i wasted so much time setting up
that joke but this is still doable
anyways based on dennis rodman is this
self-proclaimed tensai and one with a
killer headbutt hanamichi sakuragi is
the protagonist of the japanese sports
manga slam dunk by takahiko in a way
it's not often that my favorite within
the series is its protagonist but
sakuragi is not your typical main
character this hot-headed short-fused
immature gang leader is a constant
source of entertainment whenever he's on
scene whether that be on or off the
court which is largely owed to his
hilarious inner monologues that enhances
his boisterous personality sakuragi is
not a hero or not in a traditional sense
considered one of shohoku's group of
troublemakers sakuragi is a bad boy
constantly starting fights whilst a
total dweeb when it comes to girls and
unlike your typical shonen protagonists
with hidden talent or impressive lineage
sakuragi was introduced as a delinquent
with no single basketball skill except
for unusual leg power but even when at a
disadvantage due to his limited skill
set sakuragi's self-belief is unmatched
he is tenacious and determined this way
the beauty of his character lies in his
journey it's quite a ride to witness him
start his basketball career completely
from scratch the development of his
skills as a basketball player throughout
the series goes hand in hand with his
growth as a character from being a
violent delinquent whose sole reason for
getting into the game of basketball was
simply to impress a girl he likes into
gradually developing his love for the
sport and finding his purpose through
the game of basketball spoiler his
idiotic side somehow remains intact and
it's not often that the main character
is the butt of jokes but sakuragi is
built to handle these types of
situations forming the most interesting
and unique relationships with the other
characters in the series to whom
sakuragi has a habit of giving hilarious
nicknames with my favorite being his
legendary albeit one sided rivalry with
his teammate and team's best player
kaider rukawa a rivalry which i believe
set the gold standard for shonen
rivalries and is perhaps the source of
inspiration for most rivalries we adore
today and all of this makes sakuragi a
very entertaining endearing and
relatable character to follow sakuragi
completes the entire package of what you
want in a series as just one single
character he's a great source of comedy
he has great chemistry with other
characters and immediately eye-catching
design plenty of room for development
and the mental fortitude to achieve his
goals sakuragi's growth is a wonderful
journey his antics are a joy to watch
and his determination and resolve is
truly an inspiration to behold so if you
haven't already experienced this amazing
series i hope i've at least convinced
you to take a peek at hanamichi sakuragi
and enjoy the greatness that is slam
dunk this is joy girl and i'll see you
again soon what i did not see that
coming at all thanks so much joy girl
this was an absolute blast to watch i've
actually not seen slam dunk but boy am i
going to now such a positive delivery 11
out of 10 from me and it's already time
for the last contestant as well anime
ball steep who covers so many different
series on their channel i can't wait to
find out who they actually picked
okay so choosing your favorite character
isn't easy there's so many to choose
from like yagami or l from death note
lelouch from code geass freaking mugen
from samurai champloo and let's not
forget spike spiegel from cowboy bebop
truly i can go on honestly i even
consider picking mob from mob psycho as
i have truly resonated with his
character likewise with so many shonen
protagonists however hands down if i had
to choose one character i would
definitely choose ikiji onizuka not only
is he super sexy hilarious beyond
humanely strong he is literally the
greatest teacher anyone can ask for as a
young lonely friendless and misguided
teenager born and raised in the west to
immigrant parents i lack a sense of
belonging and had troubles relaying my
internal struggles weirdly enough
through the platform of anime i was able
to resonate with these fictional
characters and felt understood but also
through this means i learned how to care
and understand others out of everyone
onizuka hands down was my greatest
teacher through his down-to-earth
persona coming from a lowly background
he strived for more to break the cycle
he was living in and become something no
one would imagine him to be a teacher
who can actually teach us how to live
something which is forgotten by our own
school and educational system onizuka
along with his best friend ryuji lived
their childhood and teenage years as
delinquents like many of us onizuka also
grew up without the right guidance and
had to learn about life through the
struggles he went through these life
lessons molded him into the person he is
today but what makes onizuka different
is that he can retrospectively
understand others and with every action
he makes somehow inspires the people
around him to be better knowing this
onizuka decides he wants to become a
teacher a teacher that he himself never
had a teacher who can actually make a
difference to the lives of other people
we all start off as kids and during our
early stages in life if we were to
important life lessons then growing up
also becomes a bit easier however
sometimes teaching these life lessons
require a bit more of a personal touch
teachers in our day and age come in to
do their job relay information and then
get paid somewhere along the lines
students are no longer looked at as
human beings with actual real life
problems problems that you have at home
or even with their friends of societal
pressure or even their own insecurities
all these issues are just brushed aside
and the focal point of the schooling
system is to force us to deal with our
problems and just get good grades no
matter your circumstance if you fail you
become a outcast of society deemed to
have a shitty job no money no respect
nothing the human vr slowly gets lost by
how well or bad we do during these early
years in school this is where onizuka
comes in coming from a background where
he's deemed as nothing from the
mainstream society a perspective
embodied by the vice principal uchi
yamada onizuka overcomes all the
naysayers and eventually achieves his
dream and aspiration of becoming a
teacher not just changing his own life
but the life of others onizuka teaches
us to be empathetic and forgiving also
not to take life so seriously like even
after his own students try to get fired
by putting him in ridiculous
scrutinizing circumstances he ultimately
forgives them and helps them overcome
their own strives and if all that don't
convince you let me mention that onizuka
has a second degree black belt he's
extremely proficient in performing the
beautiful german suplex he's an expert
driver and pretty decent in playing
video games most importantly he will
jump off a building rooftop to save you
yo i absolutely love how some people
here showed me a completely fresh sight
to this this is another series i'm not
familiar with but that sounds really
worth checking out awesome job everyone
make sure to show them some love and
subscribe all their channels are of
course linked in the description below
so let's move straight on to the
evaluation bro i was genuinely taken
aback how well-made and diverse all of
these five videos were i hope you agree
that each of them did an awesome job to
present their individual person or dog
oh it's so hard to pick okay so the
entire stefan thing was so perfectly
executed despite the joke i really hope
that was a joke tekking did what he does
best making me fall in love with one
piece even more than i already am brago
did a phenomenal job on kilauea i
absolutely agree that his character is
pretty much perfect joy girl's
introduction of sakuragi and slam dunk
just as her name promised was a real joy
to watch and anime bald steep simped so
hard for onizuka that i now feel
obligated to check it out but there can
only be one winner and i'm gonna cast
the very first vote between us i was
really close to give it to liam and
stefan because i'm a real sucker for
great humor and over-the-top production
quality as well but i think i have to go
with joy girl and slam dunk this was
just too much fun to watch here's the
score let's see what everyone else
thinks hey o'hara i cast my vote for
brago's favorite character kilauea
zoldick from hunter hunter and it's not
just because i happen to be watching
hunter hunter right now in the chimera
antarctic coincidentally but no kilowatt
is pretty cool first off he has kill in
his name so right away also i'm
personally a fan of electricity and
lightning users like when it comes to
element users in fiction like fire wind
i always love someone that can just nuke
somebody with a lightning bolt instantly
cool in my books and um just like braggo
said you know gone and kilauea are sort
of like both the main characters of
hunter hunter i like to think killa was
maybe a little bit more of the main
character than gone gone i mean he does
have major character development moments
throughout most notably in the chimera
antarctic you know way further down the
line in the story but i feel like
kilauea's character is developed a lot
more by takashi in every single
character arc we find out a little bit
more about kilauea and his relationship
to gon and how he's kind of like
experiencing this world after being
basically locked in a mountain his whole
life being trained to be an assassin um
that stuff is always really interesting
to me and like killer was like
perspective on things and his fights are
usually more somber but also more badass
so yeah i cast my vote for kilauea
zoldick okay so i have a minute to tell
you guys why i chose the video that i
chose and of course i'm not going to
tell you at the beginning because well
that's no fun so first techie tagging
was talking about frankie and for me it
felt like tekking was speaking through
frankie and everything was talking about
frankie is basically because frankie was
so relatable to him being different just
being unapologetically yourself those
are things i associate with teching so
it was like of course frankie's his
favorite character one of his favorite
characters of all time because teching
is frankie that's what i get from
teching alright i gotta speed this up
joy girl was really unexpected because i
mean i've seen her on twitter and it
seems like she likes basketball but this
being her selection very interesting did
not expect it and i didn't get intrigued
by her explanation so that was good
grand line what the [ __ ] at first i was
like where the hell is this going
definitely very creative stefan but who
was that singing that's who i want to
know because i played that like two or
three times like we need to know who the
person is that was singing abd i wasn't
aware of this series at all so i went
and i googled it the explanation was
intriguing but when i googled it it said
that he was a virgin i don't know if
it's the correct thing but yeah that's
what sticks out but i guess to which one
i chose i would say grand line was
really close right because that's
singing i still need to know who that
was that was singing because that was
really good but i'm gonna go with joy
girl because ball is life
okay so now for the vote everyone made
some really great pictures anime balls
deep has convinced me to check out the
great teacher onizuka because that's a
series i haven't seen before bda law and
killua such an easy pick definitely my
favorite character from hunter hunter
and the grand line review
look
i think i think i would have voted for
stefan if it wasn't for teching and his
favorite character frankie
because
it's frankie
[Music]
but seriously before we just pin it to
my straw hat buyers taking touched on a
lot of the sentiments that i have about
frankie as a character and how he just
does not get enough love and he also
pointed out everything that i think
there is to love about frankie's
character his design his techniques and
his abilities his awesome battles and of
course his weird personality which all
makes him
super
okay so everyone's picked you know it's
pretty interesting joy girl has
definitely tempted me to watch slam dunk
turkey gave a better insight to
frankie's character than i originally
heard and grand land picking stuff on
whitebeard's dog honestly i don't know
what to say about that one but
why didn't i think of that but i'm gonna
have to vote for kilowatt honestly as
bds said even though he isn't a
protagonist he kind of is but most
importantly what's highlighted is his
relationship with god being a very
distant character with his own
psychological issues he still manages to
care for his best friend and compliment
him in every way and unlike most shonen
duos like naruto and sasuke goku and
vegeta you could even say asta and you
know relationship with gone doesn't have
to be emphasized with competition and
for those who know anime balls deep and
been watching us for a very long time
should know that we started off as a duo
where i would even say that our
relationship was kind of like gones and
killers i would go as far to say as
their relationship is probably the best
portrayal of friendship i've seen in
anime so yeah that's it for me i'm going
to have to go with bda's pick kilowatt
all right so i feel like i'm in a bit of
a tough situation here i've never seen
or read slam dunk not gto actually so
that immediately biases me pretty
heavily towards either frankie or
kilauea and in a choice between those
two quite frankly it has to go to not
frankie i think the bda did a fantastic
job of summarizing why killer is a
standout character not only in hunter
hunter but just as storytelling in
general if there was anyone in this
gigantic world of human fiction who
could be called a perfect character
kilwa would almost certainly be fighting
for that crown so that's why bda is
getting a bit of a bday for me here
today i'm sorry i did that i won't do it
again well there you have it the clear
winner is bda with his essay on kilauea
of course i got some stuff for all the
other guys as well but for brago on top
of the latest volume of one piece i went
hunting in tokyo for something even
cooler i found these really awesome
special edition magazines no idea what's
inside though and the latest volume of
hunter hunter of course as well but i
also wanted something that would really
fit in with his channel and then i found
it the perfect price what better to
represent brago than a figurine of sanji
vs zorro if you also pick hilua go check
out my not 3 but 30 minute analysis on
him here thanks so much everyone for
participating and thank you for watching